hello everyone we are pleased to have
you join us for cardinal health lab
exchange welcome to today's live
broadcast own the histology process I am
Judy Oracle a brute shall be your
moderator for today's webinar we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by leverage and
sponsored by leica like on Microsystems
is a world leader in microscopes and
scientific instruments for more
information please visit www skaam we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this presentation has
been approved for continuing education
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner of the auditorium
this will direct you to the necessaries
fight and form needed to receive your
credits this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker Andrew
rosovsky ms htl ascp andrew Lee Foskey
is the technical application manager at
leica biosystems in richmond illinois
andrew has a master's degree in
molecular biology from the north eastern
illinois university in chicago his
current role with like a bio system
involves histology training and
technical training for consumables in
histology he also works on the R&D team
for quality and supports new product
development and during his authored
publications including gene expression
analysis in rats treated with
experimental estudo co a carboxylate
inhibitors to just interactions with the
PPA our alpha pathway which was
published in the journal of pharmacology
and experimental therapeutics in 2007 I
will now turn it over to Andrew rosovsky
for his prison
thank you Ray Cobb welcome everyone harm
to another scientific webinar on so
today's talk is about the histologic
process on and you to really limited
amount of time which is on 45 minutes to
an hour um I hope you all understand
that it's not possible to really discuss
everything so what I have done I'm going
to concentrate on the steps of the
histologic process how you can own it
how can you use your education your
science your mind to use those solutions
the premium solutions for the best
optimal workflow undisrupted in the lab
so what are the goals in each and every
histo lab so of course we are choosing
the right consumables on it's crucial
for the optimal and antiseptic workflow
and we've all been there where you have
chosen maybe economy blade or economic
has said just to learn that you have to
repeat the whole process all over again
just because you didn't choose wisely so
by doing so you are you're trying to
minimize the risk of recurring work and
this is the big one armed with the big
labs are doing 5,000 or 500 fly today
you can't really step back for a block
and and do this work again so you are we
need you to use your knowledge and and
and just choose wisely and deliver the
best results without repeating your
world so we all know arm let's start
with challenging sample so we all know
the samples are some of them are easy to
work with and some of them are just
horrible are and just an examples of
those are challenging samples are
tissues that you are a process you fix
your process and you're trying to cut
and everything goes well until you stain
them and they just come off the on the
glass this is just the nature of some of
the tissues like bone cartilage
recognize just a nightmare to cartadd
stuff or those folks that work on the
from our research places feted issues
that's always the challenging breast
like breast biopsy for brain on skin is
not easy to cut and deal with our
tissues that require special processing
there's lots of them or samples that are
cutted different thicknesses and of
course the whole world of the research
were folks are dealing with marine avian
or reptile specimen this is a completely
different world for them but you have to
understand this is one histology and all
we all would try to retain that the
precious sample on the slide um so these
are the challenging samples that we all
are aware of then you have challenging
applications and there are multiple open
like crystal are immunohistochemistry so
whoever done are whoever is doing
immunity so chemistry you know that the
tissue will be most likely exposed to
high temperatures there will be repeated
washes with different buffers um some of
those will be some of those are samples
will be exposed to harsh techniques like
antigen retrieval techniques where you
are either use buffer to the high pH or
extreme temperatures ranging to all the
way to having two hundred cells you so
this is this is something that people
are aware these are challenging
applications and another one a good line
is in sight of hybridization whether
this is a color metric radioactive or
just fluorescent you also expose your
offense to the high temperatures you are
introduced those stringent sea washes on
for hours and hours and faulty buffer so
these are conditions that will try to do
everything to make your sample ah
disappear or be lost frozen sectioning
this is a challenging application also
not easy you're dealing with a non fixed
issue which is also like oh it's prone
to come of this light or a tissue very
often let's cut now that your routine
four to five or six microns these are
the tissues that many faults would
collect 20 microns and try to retain our
tissues are death take emma glass so you
need to know how to do it
what to use would fly to pick our
technique to use to help yourself to
retain the temple on the glass and of
course there are many different special
stains that would employ heat or just
plain simple impressive chemicals are
nasty and also not very friendly but you
have to use them and and so your goal is
to use our knowledge are to combat those
applications those those are conditions
um so so basically you're trying to
prevent our tissue under that is under
fixed tissue that is are there would be
a poor process or tissue that is you're
trying to avoid our tissue sections
missing or partially missing or falling
over and of course you trying to achieve
optimal staining a big one with no
background just beautiful H&E if it's an
H any are stained and avoid maybe if
something like yours and leaching they
will just change everything so these are
just a few examples I hope you
understand not possible stuff all about
the best things that can happen to a
sample these are just basic ones so what
I have done I created a histology
workflow and this is just a routine
workflow and so if you look at that
chart it's follow the arrow everything
starts from trimming you have to fix
your tissue you process your tissue and
then you embed so then stacked you
section the tissues stained covered lip
and you can just take your slides a
pathologist or you can read it yourself
and then some people which is digitize
all the slides into a hard drive and
then the last we would just store this
slide so this is a long process as you
know some hospitals would spend a day to
if it's a small biopsy sample that could
be maybe a day but there are techniques
like radioactive inside to there to
require two different developments from
the film and this very same flow will
take two months so depends who you are
where you work but the basic stuff those
are the steps that are staying for the
routines this ecology work for
so if you so so that was the simplified
if you look at the enhanced workflow we
all know that when you deal with the
bony tissue you need to employ an outer
step you need to be calcified a tissue
we'll talk about it for a few minutes
when you're dealing with the frozen
techniques to bypass few steps but then
this is something that allows you to cut
time and provide the answer to a
pathologist much faster but that's yet
another technique you embed it
differently you cut it on a different
equipment and there's no fixation and of
course if you look at the section
staining to this is not just routine H&E
you have variety of choices it's up to a
pathologist I get to ask you to do
immunohistochemistry or follow up the
inside to or even at special stains
there are more and more popular and of
course in the middle you can or you can
do a laser microdissection but you still
need to go through all those basic steps
that would lead to a section are being
put on the a glass slide so let's talk
about the arm few steps are so the first
one is that I have children is because
dedication and you if you think about
the calcification this is where people
would make her own mistakes and so
hopefully everybody is the word that you
can you can choose different assets
differently calcifying agents so the
thing is you have to be smart about it
you have to know whether to choose
strong or a weak acid whether your
sample will be are used to do immunized
or chemistry this is the case you need
you need to be you need to choose a
different de calcifying engine so so
size and density of the sample matters
for for you I mean you have to know that
the strong acid will work very fast
however you can easily over decalcify
the sample
that sample could be lost forever so you
have to be aware of it arm same with the
week I'm added when you choose to work
with a weak acid the process is much
much slower so very often on the
manufacturers will combine on this weak
acid with it from aldehyde so while you
are d calcifying the tissue that very
simple is being fixed at the same time
so it's very useful not surprisingly not
very many people know there are
different assets are and if you work if
you if your goal is immunity to
chemistry you have to be aware you
cannot use anything acid-base it most
likely would have to be something with
the EDTA a dilution fourteen percent
EDTA would work wonderfully the assets
would just simply destroy epitopes or
antigens are sitting on those epitopes
so if you're dealing with some abandoned
our protein you might get away and but
of course you have to be error of it you
have to do multiple rounds to make sure
which asset which the classifying agent
is a correct one and of course time
allowed for decalcification that needs
to be established and validated by the
institution that you work for the
excessive decalcification the
calcification the calcification time is
often seen when people tend to forget
that they had something in a jar under
the hood and you come back and the
tissue is lost goes down there will be
no morphology you can't really see
anything everything is just chewed out
also if you weren't if you are working
with a bigger samples or something very
dense and your arm agent your decalcify
engagement might be just two weeks and
it just takes forever to decalcify so
wrong or not optimal because defying
would read to are repeating at this
procedure until you get it right so you
have to get it right the first time and
so I need you to be a word are different
detoxifying agents different strengths
and depends on the technique whether the
system you know or routine this is up to
you which one you choose but we need you
to choose wisely so that's an example of
how things can go wrong on in the lab
are so another step are would be
processing arm so the processing is a is
a step that usually how people do
overnight if it searches through the
routine sample so the first thing is to
correct choice of reagents and we need
we need to know that those reagents
first of all they need to be replaced or
rotated strictly according to establish
guidelines so there is no cut cutting
corners here and some people I've seen
that would use ethyl alcohol pure ethyl
alcohol as the reagent and while this is
there would be good for some tissues
most of the time that's just too harsh
and it's maybe not necessary by using of
our region alcohol that is simply mixed
as an additive of methanol and
isopropanol would do the work um it's
inexpensive and it's also there's no BB
ATF license needed so you can you can
use rage and out all you should maybe
consider are using region alcohol to
just cut costs department this is a big
one um and there's a lot of lot of talk
on forum sister forums which person to
use um so it's up to the lab and so
there are three different kinds of
paraffin so he has paraffins designate
or design to work on to do the job the
best while doing the processing there
are two steps processor or persons that
are used for both processing and
embedding and they're just Parsons
design for our better embedding so let's
just talk about for two minutes about
the infiltration part and go I'm if you
dealing with the tissue that is our
bigger Ord enter your wise choice would
be to research a person that would
DMSO dimethylsulfoxide this is a stove
airy small tiny molecule that helps
carry a long chain carbohydrate chain of
our wax into the tissue so your
infiltration happen faster I'm they're
less are two are less chances of tissue
being under process so once you tried it
and I talked to many people over the
phone they just love it and they they
would have a big sample dense tissues
and they will just work wonderfully so
just bear in mind that if you use if you
want a premium optimal person for that
step your parents should or maybe ought
to contain that additive of DMSO another
thing that people armed tend to not pay
attention is using the right to set so
there are so many cassettes out there
and so I think the biggest is using the
right pore size which is very important
because the size of the pore is
important for the fluid exchange and we
know during the processing you have
alcohol xylene Spartans the bigger the
poll the better fluid exchange the
better processing so you will not deal
with the honda process tissue there are
cassettes that would help you with your
with your life and the left that would
have slope walls and so or no corners at
all so when you're dealing with the
small tiny biopsy of our pieces um it's
easier for you to remove those are
temples from the cassette armed with
with pointy Armed Forces there are
cassettes are designated for the biopsy
so would be mad dirt oh they have the
mesh or screen so they've been used by
people that work with the biopsies a lot
and they like they like and a lot so
also the choice of the closet so if your
lap is using a printer you have to
remember I think I fast forward sorry
about that so the answer remembered to
you
or to choose because that is optimized
for printing so the surface of the
custard is has the correct writing angle
which is very important and you might
not be aware about different
manufacturers would use different design
so some of those surfaces are at the 45
or 35 or even 50 degree angle so if you
use a cassette just because you like the
price or the color on your printer you
might not have the optimal our ink a
place on the surface because there's
just the angle it's all wrong so either
you can adjust the angle some printers
you can do it some you can or you can
just choose the best cassette that would
have the right angle and a perfect
surfer that was validated to receive the
ink and of course for speed our newest
last maybe few years components would
sell the caster that are very nicely
conveniently packed are in tubes or they
would be called sometimes stacked or
tapes I guess so if you really want to
cut time during clinical steps you would
buy those cassettes load them on the
cassette with just within two seconds
you have 60 or 80 concerts in the tube
and you can print them very easily and
of course security ah this is the big
one if you look at sample you know this
is this is the bad this is I think the
better thing that can happen in the life
you loser example just because you chose
a in fury upset with a badly designed
hinge and and it is a tragedy because
you are you how do you tell the patient
hey we need you to come back to a
hospital so another biopsy because you
lose we lose your sample so this is
something that cannot have and you have
to make sure that your cassettes are the
best of the best and of course um the
technique the processing time itself I
mean I was at the couple of years the
demonstration I saw a booklet that death
would be dedicated to processing times
that booklet has 45 pages on different
times guidelines for different
also you have general our processing
routine small and large animals or
biopsy skin then he has the times for
specialized tissues like boron bones or
dental samples or even special tissues
like marine or reptiles people due
process corals and that's completely
different time so all the times you need
to be aware and most of you always are
those times differs from simple sample
so you have to be aware of it and so
when you do a poor job when you do not
use your best part and what happens I
mean that part of in that temple most
likely will become brittle or impossible
to cut you have to go back if you lucky
enough to have another sample you can
redo it again but what do you do with
the sample it is fully processed it's
basically sample is lost so it's very
bad I'm also a little sad when the
cassette when the ink are you choose the
wrong cassette or inferior quality
cassettes and the ink on the surface of
the cassette being is resolved due to
heat or the reagents and the processor I
mean don't forget that cassettes are
exposed to our harsh reagents I mean
alcohol signing are 60 degrees Celsius
of paraffin that's not very friendly for
the ink so if you lose that just because
the ink doesn't sit well on the surface
of the plastic cassette it's really bad
because you can't really tell whose
temple is it and let the last thing you
are wanting to happen in the lab arm so
the next step arm is embedding um so
embedding trying to fast forward so
embedding first technique so you need to
of course use your best techniques
orientation it to be aware of the right
orientation whether you are embed a
cultist calcified long piece of tissue
or a skin sample you need to know how to
do it on you how you may want to use the
correct mode
oh and by saying correct mall the mall
that would help your life there are most
out there that will limit your time
while scraping the blog because it's
they really really are forgiving in
terms of overflowing so you might want
to know that and of course avoid
excessive heat like temperature of the
embedding center that would ruin your
samples in choosing the right optimal
and beating media that's the big one
that's the person that you would like to
use would contain a polymer or a
container die to make your life much
easier so polymer is what they do arm
components like us or i would add
polymers not even one but combination of
different polymers different sizes just
to make that embedding media a little
harder so when that person solidifies
it's harder therefore it's easier to
Carthage is dealing with the place on
that biopsy step 2 microns honest to god
your church should be a nod to be and
embedding with the polymer unloaded with
it actually so your life is stories you
have flawless sections there's no
compression so also by adding polymer
you can play with the melting
temperature time I'm point so those are
polymer containing media they usually
have elevated are melting point of 58 60
degrees which is good this is what you
want while you cut this section this is
not the media you want to use y
infiltrating the tissue this is the
media you want to use when making your
beautiful blocks there are patterns out
there that would contain died and one
might say why would you want to die in a
polymer in a media in the product and
I'm sorry so whenever you're dealing
with the OPEC tissue white tissue and
you're dealing with the liquid so our
are clear paraffin it's sometimes very
hard to see it's not impossible if
you're dealing with a small tiny biopsy
if you use a slightly tinted person
let's say with the blue or red color
whatever it is you see that sample right
away so you
cut time while embedding you are more
comfortable under less chances of are
using the tissue you will not be
disappointed while using it it's really
really friendly that contract that the
person will give you between a clear
liquid clear paraffin and a white or
pack tissue ah and of course the words
when you lose the sample because you
just can't see it done damage myself I
was dealing with some neonatal over it
at some point and I just chose that way
I will on I didn't have money at that
time for that or the Constitution didn't
have money for that I just love couple
of the samples that was the best thing
that happened to me I learned hard way
now whenever I'm dealing with this small
tissue like that I would use the person
there would just help me to do the job
better I'm so Lex I'm betting arm part
so on the next step I would be
sectioning I'm for sectioning um so this
is where basically two things happen so
you need a right blade and you need a
right glass this is a big one so the art
of sectioning really cuz this is really
an art of using the right blade blade is
really a science people saying well it's
just a sharp blade what's the difference
you know so you need to remember that
the blades are made differently they are
all economy blades are the best blade
some plates you can copy ten sections
with some blades will last much longer
and then depends how the blade is made
so beware of course there are high
profiles and low profile blade a high
profile since they have little more
steel thing about it when you cut when
you use them on a dense tissue and bony
tissue they will vibrate less you don't
see the vibration but the tissue will
spew it so using high profile blade if
you using hard tissues might help you
the blade design on whether this is
double triple sensor so the blade angle
which could be 35 or even 22 degrees
then
can help you to achieve Europe sections
way better way better they'll beaches
that are looking sections and of course
coding this is how this is a big one
everybody does it differently but you
really have to be educated about your
choices you know depending what are you
cutting the most often and this is this
is what depth at the choice you have to
make you have to be educated about the
blades so the blades when you use a good
blade there's no chance of going back
and doing many recaps due to poor
quality of the blade or tissue folding
over and the another a big one is the I
think this is the actually the biggest
here in their chart I'm choosing the
right glass slide for your tissue type
and staining applications so first of
all if a sustaining application like
immunohistochemistry are inside do you
know right of the bed that you will need
help to retain that tissue on the glass
slide so you most like you would want to
have a coded slide if it's a tissue that
is cut at a sticker on thickness also
your choice would be hey i need help i
need a slider is coated and of course
companies would use different coatings
on different metals methods how you know
with application metals how to put that
coating on the surface so the colored
slides would promote tissue adhesion and
also i know if you know but this lighter
not all alike there are slides are made
from white glass or green glass so green
glass would be your economy glass and
white glass would be your premium class
and for example if you work and you
would say what's the difference really
i'm doing just routine as well as well
in that case maybe wouldn't be a
difference but if you're doing once in a
while or if you do after resonance title
um you might want to stick with a white
glass at the premium grants because the
green glass have a higher content of
higher on that can immunofluorescence
under the
darkfield so you might have false with
false positive results so you want to
avoid that to burn my white glass versus
green green glass also the way the
slides are coded or the compound so that
component that I use amino access
compounds that are using our proteins or
polymers this is it our latest
techniques so the premium slides
differently coded and also the method is
very important so depending how you
called your slides you would achieve
different properties of course you can
dilute the amino acids or protein or
polymer differently and therefore you
will achieve different properties of the
title no not all the coded flights are
alike just bear in mind so and also the
big one people say hey what is the
really a hydrophobic and hydrophilic
slightly worn it is all about so all the
colored slides are hydrophobic um just
by adding this adhesive whether it is
amino acid or a polymer that stuff
repels water so repels water is just a
hydrophobic water heading surface and
this is what you this is what you want
for the heart arm to or easy to lose
tissue hydrophilic slides are still
hydrophobic I know it's confusing so
hydrophilic slides has hydrophilic
properties because your arm slides will
promote greater homogeneous spread of
the applied solution and you can use it
to your advantage for example if you're
working on immunohistochemistry and you
have your precious antibody or precious
a secondary or whatever it is you will
use you might want to use less of
solutions because that solution will
occupy a bigger area thanks to
hydrophilic properties of the
hydrophobic side so so coating that
matter of course clip corner slides
regular slide for clip corner slides
other slides to help you with a speed so
so when you use your printer
those people's work very well because
there's less chance to for the glass
breakage for bread fragmentation so
there's no jamming now you can do your
work much faster of course we are
specialized slide like devil slides you
know they great for the blacksmith we
all know that but because they never
when you drag the slider gave the slide
you and the friction is much ready to
reduce so there's no glass powder or
glad that on the slide that receives the
blood smear on they are slight I don't
know if you're aware there are coded
specifically for the thermal printers so
that's a big one too if you have a
thermal printer you might want to check
with slide is the best for my printer on
and off there are slides that will help
you with to work with your special
stains the slides we have our a line
that divides the field into two and it
just allows you to put a control
positive control tissue on this very
same slide so when you go back you have
your negative you have unknown and your
pockets on one slide so it just makes
your life much easier more streamline um
and two words on a waterbed adhesive
edit if those people who choose to add
their own additives to the water best to
code this slides while picking up the
tissue this is a great method as well
but you have to remember that you cannot
add too much to the water bed you cannot
overdo it and of course you cannot use
the coated slides and call them again in
the water bed um I was reading the
scientific publication and they were
actually looking at the layers of the
coating on the glass slide and ideally
dead coding should be between three to
seven layers so if you overdo it and
create 20 layers you think okay i'm
going to call it a little more it'll be
better at he says well it's not you
you're doing yourself at this favor
because that tissue that sits on top
it's just being too unstable and chances
are you will lose it during the
subsequent of staining so um
so we have your our slides and we need
to staining so staining again there are
so many different that methods your
routine H&E and of course specialized
training immuno and side two and and and
and special things so first of all you
need to achieve perfect coloration hi
how do you do it really so each steps
are in the staining process has to be
accurately time so there's no cutting
corners here as well and but it's up to
you which train do you use is it staying
down by the company that makes it or is
it some of itself to you and they really
don't know the chemistry behind it so i
really like when i was working in the
lab with different stains I really like
a places that I would call and ask
questions you know how what is the ph
what happens if the i mix this component
with that component so this is up to you
but you have to go with the best because
that stain is how as the pathologist
will make a decision so choosing the
progressive versus regret this method
choosing the right source of hematoxylin
our differentiator a big one so if it's
a a hydrochloric acid base haha of
differentiator you might want to
consider up another one that has a
organic acid that is gentler on your
slides are gentler of the bond that is
being formed between our glass and a
tissue and also weaker weaker
differentiators um they would clear
goblet cells with the muse and in it
some people don't just like the dark
image of the mutant and the goblet cells
that's kind of distracts from the
nucleus painting so i'm just telling you
there are different nap or the
differentiator are the same like many
many different hematoxylin and i'm
looking at my clock it's 1040 so i need
to go a little faster here so lining and
signings retaining a big one lately we
all want to be environment-friendly so
they're a lot of push to
substitute designing the designing free
product you have to remember you need to
make necessary adjustments for that so
whenever you use in signing free our
clearance the time needs to be increased
you need to rotate sometimes twice you
need to rotate or change that a product
to avoid using Legion because that water
that gets to the dining free our
clearance really has a great affinity to
eels and Phil even is so the water is
pulling even from the slides so you have
to remember there are you this is just
not as simple substitution have to be
aware that using dining free reagents
you need to increase time um and of
course going back to the slides when you
choose your slides with the amino acids
are they are covered with amino acids
but in mind that your section might give
you a little bit of a blue background
this is well known phenomena maybe if
you if you go with a polymer coated you
might improve your appearance of this
slide um so lastly are the last thing so
you have your say in beautiful stained
you have to protect this thing you
protect the stain with the coverslip
instead so covering sleep step also
people do not pay attention to do this
fact that you can really ruin your slide
here let me advance the slide here a
little bit there you go so first of all
is it automated or is it a manual you
have to remember about the proper cover
cover switch settings people completely
forget about that that there are
different natural gauges on those cover
sleeper so depending which are mounting
media you use they do have different
viscosity so that volume needs to be
adjusted bigger novel smaller nozzle
media drop positioning you need to be
but this is done that could be done over
the phone by engineer you can do it
yourself just be aware that too much too
little can really make your wire I'm
life harder because you need to go back
and restock the slides a long process as
you know
to recover slip the slides so the cover
glass for the automated process this is
a this is the cover slip that it's
actually designated for the automated
process where the extra step is added
during the manufacturing process to
prevent sticking so you might want to
consider you probably stink covers cover
glass or machine trying to pick up a
single cover glass and unfortunately due
to the humidity or poor quality of the
cover glass then machine would peak to
and the machine Jen just stops because
it senses it's got more than one
individual cover slips so the choice of
color glass is important unit one that
are glass slides just hanging in the
machine waiting to be covered slave
drying and so just slowing the process
interrupting the workflow and the proper
selection of multimedia lastly you know
the compatibility between aromatic and
aliphatic which is basically designing
and lining substitute products you need
to be a word to you need to be aware
that you need to be choose wisely when
you are using tiny substitutes at the
last station in your strainer you really
need a silent about immediate at its
base and the very same our clearance our
BHT sense for beauty or hydroxytoluene
hydroxytoluene this is just an anti
fading agent people would go back years
later to some old cases try to review
and guess what pain is completely faded
and if you use a multimedia that doesn't
have it that might happen so make sure
that the mounting media would contain
that antioxidant anti-aging agent so
these all are tabs that can really help
you in the lab so just be aware of door
of those challenges and and and if you
are the more you educated the better
your choices are you need to be error of
your choice other in the market so you
can minimize repeating your work or
going back and do it all over again you
can
Chris easily you can decrease time and
laboratory costs by not revealing stuff
by using sometimes maybe more little bit
more expensive product but you know it
will work every single time so you are
optimizing your workflow and all that
reads basically to improving performance
and patient care where you can give a
beautiful slide to the pathologist and
the shortest possible time I guess that
was my last slide so thank you very much
I hope you understand in such a short
time I couldn't possibly touch on
everything so thank you thank you for
that informative presentation I'm
thrilled to be part of cardinal health
lab exchange before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and see it looks at
this point we don't have any questions
for Andrew but we encourage you to head
over to the community of learning
following this presentation to engage in
a live chat with Andrew and your peers
and continue the discussion regarding
the histology process I would like to
thank our sponsor leica for making
today's educational webcast possible
please please again make sure to visit
the community of learning to speak with
andouille sausage and and discuss the
histology process today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through October of this year you'll
receive an email from lab roots to
learning new women's webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
for that announcement to your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
see you next time bye